[Music]
why is it so difficult to cure cancer
we've harnessed electricity sequenced
the human genome and eradicated smallpox
but after billions of dollars in
research we haven't found a solution for
a disease that affects more than 14
million people and their families at any
given time
cancer arises as normal cells accumulate
mutations most of the time cells can
detect mutations or DNA damage and
either fix them or self-destruct
however some mutations allow cancerous
cells to grow unchecked and invade
nearby tissues or even metastasize to
distant organs cancers become almost
incurable once they metastasize
and cancer is incredibly complex it's
not just one disease there are more than
100 different types and we don't have a
magic bullet that can cure all of them
for most cancers treatments usually
include a combination of surgery to
remove tumors and radiation and
chemotherapy to kill any cancerous cells
left behind hormone therapies
immunotherapy and targeted treatments
tailored for a specific type of cancer
are sometimes used to
in many cases these treatments are
effective and the patient becomes
cancer-free but they're very far from
100% effective 100% of the time
so what would we have to do to find
cures for all the different forms of
cancer we're beginning to understand a
few of the problem scientists would have
to solve first of all we need new better
ways of studying cancer most cancer
treatments are developed using cell
lines grown in labs from cultures of
human tumors these cultured cells have
given us critical insights about cancer
genetics and biology but they lack much
of the complexity of a tumor in an
actual living organism it's frequently
the case that new drugs which work on
these lab-grown cells will fail in
clinical trials with real patients one
of the complexities of aggressive tumors
is that they can have multiple
populations of slightly different
cancerous cells over time distinct
genetic mutations accumulate in cells in
different parts of the tumor giving rise
to unique subclones for example
aggressive brain tumors called
glioblastoma
can have as many as six different sub
clones in a single patient this is
called clonal heterogeneity and it makes
treatment difficult because a drug that
works on one sub clone may have no
effect on another here's another
challenge a tumor is a dynamic
interconnected ecosystem where cancer
cells constantly communicate with each
other and with healthy cells nearby they
can induce normal cells to form blood
vessels that feed the tumor and remove
waste products they can also interact
with the immune system to actually
suppress its function keeping it from
recognizing or destroying the cancer
if we could learn how to shut down these
lines of communication we'd have a
better shot at vanquishing a tumor
permanently
additionally mounting evidence suggests
we'll need to figure out how to
eradicate cancer stem cells these are
rare but seem to have special properties
that make them resistant to chemotherapy
and radiation in theory even if the rest
of the tumor shrinks beyond detection
during treatment a single residual
cancer stem cell could seed the growth
of a new tumor figuring out how to
target these stubborn cells might help
prevent cancers from coming back
even if we solved those problems we
might face new ones cancer cells are
masters of adaptation adjusting their
molecular and cellular characteristics
to survive under stress when they're
bombarded by radiation or chemotherapy
some cancer cells can effectively switch
on protective shields against whatever
is attacking them by changing their gene
expression malignant cancers are complex
systems that constantly evolve and adapt
to defeat them we need to find
experimental systems that match their
complexity and monitoring and treatment
options that can adjust as the cancer
changes but the good news is we're
making progress even with all we don't
know the average mortality rate for most
kinds of cancer has dropped
significantly since the 1970s and is
still falling we're learning more every
day and each new piece of information
gives us one more tool to add to our
arsenal history repeats but science
reverberates that's a quote from the
Pulitzer Prize winning book the Emperor
of all maladies a biography of cancer we
highly recommend you read or listen to
this extraordinary book if you visit
audible.com slash Ted Edie you can
download an audio version of this book
for free Ted Edie is a non-profit and
using either of these methods to select
your next great book helps us continue
to create free educational videos for
everyone